foreign
I'm Jay-Z
not the cool rapper
but the professor trying to cool the
planet through Behavior change
the other day I gave my students an
assignment I asked them to come up with
individual actions they can take that
serve two functions
reduce greenhouse gas emissions and make
themselves feel happier
they did a great job coming up with
actions to reduce emissions
but they had a much harder time with the
happiness part
one student told me that he wanted to
come back on cheese
but right after he said that he got
really sad
unfortunately my students are not alone
what most people think about climate
action they immediately default the
things that have to give up for the
planet
this mindset is so ingrained in US
partly because the current narrative on
climate action is about personal
sacrifice
Drive less eat less Meat Shop less less
less less
now I'm a behavioral scientist so trust
me when I say this this framing doesn't
make us feel great
if anything it makes us feel shameful
and guilty
and those negative motions are not
conducive to long-term Behavior change
because they make us Retreat and
disengage
if the future of a planet depends on a
few people willing to make personal
sacrifices we're not going to make it
so what should we do instead
the aha moment came to me at the end of
a faculty meeting when my colleague
Elizabeth Dunn approached me and asked
can we make climate action feel happy
instead of miserable
I said of course
but then it struck me that I don't think
anyone ever connected happiness to
climate action
so Liz and I sat down to do exactly that
this is a happiness scientist she knows
what makes people happy
I'm a behavioral scientist I know what
makes people change their behavior
I'm also a human carbon calculator
I like figuring out exactly how much
emissions certain activities have
so first I came up with a list of
actions that can substantially reduce
greenhouse gas emissions
and then Liz identify the actions with
the largest happiness benefits
and this is how we came up with what we
call the happy climate approach
its actions in The Sweet Spot that not
only reduce emissions but also make you
feel happier at the same time
now I know that some of you might think
that individual actions may seem trivial
without large-scale system change I get
that
but let me tell you how I think about
this as a behavior change expert
our individual actions do matter because
they embody our values and our care for
the planet to other people
they can spread like a ripple effect to
instigate Collective action
they send a market signal to businesses
and they can trigger broader structural
institutional change so yes we do need
system change but we also need
individual Behavior change
don't let anyone tell you otherwise
all right now I want to take you on a
whirlwind tour through some of my
favorite happy climate actions are you
ready
great
let's start with my pet bunny
since this is the year of the rabbit
a few years ago my partner and I adopted
Greenwich
she's adorable
she's also a vegan
we have so many plants with vegetables
and fruits in our house thanks to
Greenwich
and because of that I'm eating a lot
more vegetables myself than I used to
and I'm not kidding I'm feeling a lot
happier
eating more plants can reduce
agricultural emissions by up to 80
percent
I guess that part you may have known
before
but do you also know that a plant-based
diet can make you feel happier
Decades of medical studies suggest that
a plant-based diet can increase both
physical and mental health
in a recent experiment researchers
recruiting people from North Dakota who
barely ate any vegetables
and they fed these people a plant-based
diet for two months
these people on this diet felt a lot
happier at the end of two months and
they did before they started the
experiment
so researchers think that this is
because plants so fruits vegetables are
high in vitamins and phytochemicals that
provide both antioxidants and
anti-inflammatory benefits to the brain
and the body
so the happy climate action here is eat
more plants
but this does not mean never eat meat
because I can tell you that deprivation
is a disaster for happiness
instead we should aim for the right
balance of meat and plants in our diet
that will make us maximally happy
now as you're thinking about this diet
and this balance understand that not all
meat is created equal
one kilogram of beef emits about a
hundred kilograms of greenhouse gases
that's roughly the same as driving 250
miles
but other types of meat like fish pork
and poultry have a lot lower emissions
but if you do want to eat beef here's
the happy climate hack make it a treat
one study shows that temporarily giving
up something we enjoy can actually renew
our capacity to have to savor that thing
when we have it again and that can
increase our happiness
and Beyond food we can turn other things
into a treat as well like shopping
now you know that fast fashion has a
huge climate impact
so instead of shopping often
make shopping a treat
and here's the happy climate hack
jackets jeans shoes have a lot of
greenhouse gas emissions
so treating ourselves to high quality
versions of these products that won't
fall apart after a few wears is actually
good for the planet
underwear on the other hand have pretty
low emissions so you know please buy
those whenever you need them
you're welcome
now let's talk about waste
do you know that if your space is clean
zero waste and organized you may feel
happier
let's take a look at perhaps the
messiest part of everybody's home the
fridge
some environmental experts recommend
that we put perishables into the drawers
and put the condiments at the door
I hate to say this but I disagree
I don't think the fridge is designed
with human behavior in mind
we often forget about the things in the
drawers right outside out of mind and
that can lead to a lot of food waste and
Emissions so what's the happy climate
action here
Feng Shui your fridge
this is how iPhone should my fridge
by moving the perishables to the door
and the condiments into the drawers
so I can catch things before they rot
I also five-fold my fridge that is first
in first out meaning moving older items
to the front of the fridge so I don't
forget about them this way you can have
zero waste clean fridge and you may feel
happier
now Beyond ways we have to talk about
travel and here's the happy climate hack
instead of saying Drive less we should
say drive more
people
yes
some studies suggest that the more time
we spend with our friends and family the
happier we feel
so what this means is that instead of
driving alone in our car
we should drive our friends
because carpooling can turn those
Dreadful minutes behind the wheel into
joyful moments of socializing
or you can ditch the car altogether and
bike
better yet bike with your buddy
biking is virtually carbon free
and it also offers moderate exercise
that activates our endocannabinoid
system and that contributes to a sense
of euphoria that's Biker's high and
greater mental well-being
now we also know that flying is common
intensive
one round trip between Vancouver and New
York emits about half a ton of
greenhouse gases that's equivalent to
400 chicken burgers that's a lot of
burgers
but what's exciting here is that there's
a double happy climate hack here ready
first bundle your trips
this means combining multiple trips into
one by meeting up with friends and
family and maybe doing a little sizing
in the region to reap the happiness
benefits of social connection
I flew here to New York from Vancouver
for this conference and I'm meeting up
with my friends in New York to be
happier
second
cutting out unnecessary flights can
contribute to a sense of time affluence
and that is the feeling that you have
enough time to do what you want to do
Studies have shown that people who
experience time affluence tend to be
happier
because enhances our sense of
mindfulness autonomy and connection to
others
in a recent study people felt happier
when they made a time-saving purchase
than a material purchase because the
time saving Purchase made them feel less
stressed so before you book your next
flight think about all the other trips
you have to take in the future and ask
yourself whether you can bundle these
flights to save your future self some
time
now do you want to know the best part of
this whole happy climate strategy
it doesn't have to stay at the
individual level
we can actually call for happy climate
policies that governments can enact
so that everyone can get a chance to
take these happy climate actions
let me give an example
cities should invest more in
climate-friendly infrastructure like
bike Lanes so more people get to bike
cities can also invest more in
nature-based Solutions like Urban green
spaces
that not only help cool the city down
during the summer
but they also provide space to take a
walk to meet your neighbors to walk your
bunny
and then you can feel happier in fact
some studies show that taking a walk in
nature makes people feel happier than
taking a walk on a city street
I think you get the gist here
and I encourage you to take a moment and
think about the actions you can take in
your own life and not only reduce
emissions but also can make yourself
feel happier there's probably a lot of
those in this sweet spot so please get
creative
because the bottom line is this
we need to change the narrative on
climate action
we need to make climate action feel good
because if we get this right our future
will indeed be happy
thank you
[Applause]